[Music]
[Music]
I'm the one
all right all right all right episode
227 with the man to met the legend
Dennis Prager if you don't know who he
is whatever you do go study this man his
philosophies his teachings if you do
know who he is you must be fired up
about today's podcast Dennis thank you
for coming on it's always good to be
with you and this is the first time I'm
in your studio yes you've been to my
home yes I've been to your home and I
remember uh when uh uh I I had a show
with kkla I want to say save in America
you were on care early obviously you ran
the whole thing you were there all the
time I came in one time and met you
2010. they said that's the great Dennis
Prager they said that the great Dennis
Prager who yes well they're paid to say
it have you lived up to it though that's
the thing have you lived out to the last
13 years only others can judge that
but I aspire to doing good things since
high school
I I wrote in my high school diary and
it'll sound corny but I'll I'll risk it
I know exactly what I want to do with my
life influence people to the good how
did you know that then early on there is
no answer to that question I uh but I
learned something interesting from my
older son when he was about 18 19 years
old
and he said to me he said dad you have
to understand you were you are very
lucky and I said I know I am but what
are you referring to
they said you knew so at such a young
age what you wanted to do with your life
he said most people don't
and it was it's one of the great things
of having children it it Roots you in
reality
and I realized wow I don't know why I I
I knew that at such a young age
but I I'm living out what I wrote in my
diary how do you not know that though
like you couldn't say like a person you
saw speak or a smell
nothing the only thing I can tell you is
I always hated evil
uh I I I am the living embodiment of my
favorite biblical verse those of you who
love God must hate evil I love it
because if you don't hate evil you don't
love God and a lot of Believers in God
need to need to hear that it's it's so
I I always hated evil
and
I I
realized in high school that I could
touch people
uh
not in some mystical sense but I could
touch their mind or their heart
and that I had a gift of clarity
uh
I'll I mean since you're asking I feel
funny talking about me but I guess I'm
your guest it's always someone expected
uh so this is a it's actually cute and
almost funny so my father was a CPA a
certified public accountant and he we
lived in Brooklyn New York he had his
office in Manhattan but on Sundays he
worked at home in his home office in the
finished basement we had in Brooklyn
and some of his clients
you know middle-aged men would come an
hour early
to talk to me
so I said to one of them
I don't understand why do you I'm I'm
15. why do you come to talk to me and
the guy just looked at me and said
you're very interesting
and you don't know there's really no way
to know yourself without input from
others because others are a mirror you
how do you know what you look like
you can't just do it by feeling your
face so old soul type of a thing yes
philosophies yeah ideas both both of
them got it but I was I was an old soul
in a very kid-like personality which
that also has never left me is there
videos of you at that age or no no no
because there was there were no video I
I wish believe me uh uh there were there
were a handful of pictures so your dad
never went on Instagram and recorded
anything of you that's a fair I'll
disappointing Fair State how
disappointing correct but were you were
you a guy that uh when you as an old
soul I'm assuming it's very hard to date
younger girls you were dating women
older than you or no I I I I always
women my age but you're entirely right
for that was a something I almost gave
up on in my 20s I didn't marry till 32.
and this is no knock on on the women of
my age but
okay I'll tell you this you'll love this
story so I was at a bar I don't even
drink but I was at some bar
and for whatever reason and it was a
cute girl and I you know I chatted her
up as the Brits say and I I felt I was
making some progress
and then I really thought I was going to
make progress she says what do you do
and I said oh I go around the country
giving lectures which I thought at 25 is
pretty damn impressive right and she
goes naturally what do you speak on
and
when I tell you what I answered I'm
laughing at me I said ethical monotheism
very sexy yeah that's right it's like
the anti-very sexy is there's very sexy
here and in the book of opposites is
ethical monotheism yeah so that was the
last time I actually said ethical
lototheism well to the to the to the
type of girls that like big words that
could have really gone in the right
direction yeah well apparently she did
not yeah apparently she didn't know she
probably thought as one woman did
another well this was a middle-aged
woman I wasn't trying to pick her up but
I was flying through a speech I think it
was Kentucky actually and she said oh
what brings you to uh Louisville and I
go on giving a speeches oh oh on what
and I said monotheism
because I I dropped the ethical and she
goes oh let me tell you about my
rheumatism
so it was it was not a success Draeger
uh answer yeah did you play it up
because one time I'm telling this girl
at a club in Nashville Tennessee
and she says so you know what
nationality are you I said uh I'm a
Syrian
you said oh you're Sicilian I said
honestly moving forward I'm sick of
explaining what Assyrians are I said
you're right I am Sicilian it's a lot
easier
I became vintage I'm a doctor tell me
about your roommate system
I should have followed your uh you
should have played again anyway so
here's what I want to do with the
limited time that we got here today I
got a few topics I want to go through
with you one is Kanye with what happened
with them obviously it's nothing that's
relevant today but I want to know how uh
you viewed what he said some of the
criticism that he had and you know what
caused him to lose his brand the
billions of dollars Tate an aspect of
Tate I want to talk to you about
uh there was I don't know if you saw
this one guy name is just a regular guy
named Joe he was driving his Corvette he
was backing up into his garage and they
found some Declassified documents in his
garage we're going to talk about this
guy named Joe if you're following his
story or not he he had a pretty
important job and then a couple other
things that we have is around uh
fatherlessness stats so I would like to
start off with uh by the way I have no
thoughts on the Tate issue I'll tell you
in advance I uh it's actually not a take
a question oh okay it's not a take
question it is just let me explain why
because just so people have a better
sense
uh I don't find
um the people who are in the news for
two weeks interesting I have never
followed the most popular issue of the
day almost never uh not on my in 40
Years of broadcasting I'm the big
picture guy and and people get caught up
for example uh uh you know Harry and
Megan I've devoted about 10 minutes to
them
uh and all of all ten negative I thought
you watched a whole documentary and you
followed it all unimpressed with that
couple yeah to bad-mouth your family
forget whether they're the Royals
to go to the world to bad mouth your
family
I mean who doesn't have issues with
family
but to to use them
as as some sort of prop
to to make an impression and make and
sell a vast number of books
these are they strike me as just empty
children
I feel bad for the royal family I mean
you know to be honest his brother has
class I love class I love I love dignity
he it's like one brother has dignity and
one brother has no dignity
anyway I got that out of my system and
by the way just out of curiosity how
much of that is on him of uh them
embarrass in the family how much of them
is on the wife you know you know the
whole thing that's unknowable but you
know
uh if it's to the extent that it's on
the wife doesn't speak much for his
strength as a man
I agree one of the definitions of
masculinity is to be not intimidated by
women
that's that's a I I I I hold that to be
a defining element that doesn't mean God
forbid you mistreat women that one has
nothing to do with the other and I mean
God forbid you but but to be intimidated
by women means you're not masculine how
did you learn that
that's a great question
how did I learn that
like that's well a book somewhere no no
I learned by your experience back back
here I feel funny but back to me and and
my brain
uh I I'm an observer of The Human
Condition one of the aims I had I had so
many AIMS in all as a kid one of them
was to understand life
if if you want to give one word to a say
what I do I explain
I try to explain life to people I try to
explain why America is in the terrible
position that it is today the freest
country in the world half of who
citizens don't value Free Speech the
most important freedom of all I I always
ask why
and people use terms like masculine and
I value masculinity and femininity and I
believe there are only two Sexes no no I
take that back I know there are only two
Sexes I fell into a trap saying I
believe there are only two Sexes we
gotcha I got me so you're he he him I am
but but it wasn't assigned it was
assigned to me by Nature by biology and
by God
in whatever order you wish to choose
Dennis let me go back to something you
said you know we'll get into this stats
here in a minute and Rob I know I got to
do the spawn I do I'll do the
sponsorship in about five minutes but
you said something earlier you said ever
since I was a kid I wanted to fight evil
you can stay on that link uh so I can
remember it you said ever since I was a
kid I wanted to fight evil that's what
you said that's right okay so you know
evil uh if you're 15 you know that's a
few decades ago how different was evil
then than it is today so evil then is
what year that's what what year were you
50. so I was it was the late 60s okay so
late 60s what was evil in the late 60s
and what have you seen the evolution of
evil from then to today
evil is is fairly consistent communism
is evil Nazism is evil uh Islam islamism
not Islam islamism is evil where you
deliberately hurt other human beings uh
is evil
I've never found that a complex subject
and uh
if people are not clear that the three
things I mentioned are evil there is
something wrong with their moral compass
it's broken I mean if you can't
acknowledge how evil but the truth is
the ignorance I'll tell you the there's
only one difference
to answer your question between then and
now
you say to a kid in high school
Auschwitz or Gulag he doesn't know what
the hell you're talking about
that's really that border is on evil not
to teach young people about the greatest
evils just of the last century and to a
great extent of all of history Gulag and
Auschwitz
is a crime they know preferred pronouns
they're taught to be basically idiots
that's that's what look
non-impressive people are teaching
people to be non-impressive that is the
state of American Education in one
sentence
non-impressive people are teaching
people to be non-impressive yes so so
you're saying Evil's been evil for for
the last however many forever since
humans well but let me ask you this let
me let me uh maybe I want to get a
little bit extract a little bit more out
of you on this topic so uh you know how
like this new Chad gbt comes out oh my
god look what it's doing people are
using it as customer service but it's
only 1.0 wait till 2.0 3.0 5.0 7.0 iOS I
don't know what version we're on right
now 16 or 15 hey the new operating
system is 16.0 it's better than what it
was at eight point or 3.0 is the evil
49.0 today has it evolved into even
stronger ways to divide to manipulate to
pin of parents against kids husbands
against wives men against women has it
evolved to be stronger today or Has the
strength been the same forever men have
gotten weaker
there are new relatively new phenomena
the general evil is is the same evil as
it's always been what the Chinese
Communist party and the North Korean
Communist Party does to its people uh
what Putin is doing in Ukraine I mean
these are these are evils
totalitarianism is a modern evil you
need mass communication and Mass police
and mass technology to have
totalitarianism but otherwise but what
you what is new in America
uh is uh for uh I'll give you a
relatively new evil the vast number of
adult children who do not speak to
parents because they differ with the
parents conservatism
this is new
we uh it was unheard of in the past that
you stopped talking to your parent
because of how they voted
and I consider that evil that's what I
mean no evil that's not the new evil
what else is new evil
um
well in in America this is not a new
evil in the world but in America the
suppression of free speech the amount of
censorship is is brand new America
El Woodrow Wilson flirted with it
but outside of the Woodrow Wilson era we
have never had a suppression of free
speech that was the one thing every
every American agreed with 45 percent of
Young Americans according to Pew which I
tend to trust
say the following
I believe in free speech except for hate
speech and they don't realize because
they they've not been taught to think
logically they don't realize that that's
an oxymoron it's a self-contradictory
statement if you don't believe in free
speech for hate speech you don't believe
in free speech what do you believe in
free speech for only speech you agree
with everything else is hate speech this
is what the leftist taught them
and the left has never from Vladimir
Lenin to Columbia University the left
has never allowed descent
and there's a reason if there's dissent
there's no left
if there's dissent there's no love
correct they cannot that's why they shut
down conservative speakers four years of
left-wing indoctrination at the average
University is not enough they know one
conservative eloquent speaker
in in an hour and a half can undo four
years of the lies that they're told of
America being systemically racist of of
their not of there being more than two
Sexes Etc that's why they don't want us
on their campus
conservatives never gave a damn if a
liberal came to a campus they invited
them Jerry Falwell invited Ted Kennedy
to to Liberty University he
I am a conservative I ache to have I
have offered money
to any left-wing New York Times
columnist which means any one of the 99
that were left-wing
to debate I've offered ten thousand
dollars plus any money that they would
raise at uh for admission and they could
pick the venue they could pick uh the
moderator
and I would still do it they don't do it
they don't debate they smear
uh about a six herb sexist intolerant
xenophobic homophobic islamophobic race
is bigoted I had to make an acronym
because it's a lot of terms what was
that again that acronym sex is six herb
s-i-x-h-i-r-b break it down again sexist
intolerant xenophobic homophobic
islamophobic racist bigoted name calling
that's all they do because they they
can't debate they can't stand up and
tell you there are more than two Sexes
are there more than two sexes in
kangaroos
in penguins
but all of a sudden you reach the human
species and there are more than two
Sexes 56 if you sign up for Facebook 56
were living in the age of the Absurd of
the total absurd and by the way I have a
reason for that secularism
the post
judeo-christian World produces only
idiocy
no religious person says there are more
than two Sexes the only people who say
there are more than two Sexes the only
people who say men give birth are
secular
secularism produces morons not every
secular person is a [ __ ] of course not
but every secular institution is moronic
and the most secular institution is the
University and that's where all the
moronic ideas originate how do they keep
making so much advancement
how how are
uh you know Concepts that literally make
no sense
create this kind of momentum uh there
was an answer given by G.K Chester
thinner at least attributed to him late
19th century early 20th century British
thinker when people stop believing in
God they don't believe in nothing they
believe in anything
that's the answer to your question
people don't even secular conservatives
don't agree with me they think
secularism is is a blessing it's only a
blessing in government that is not a
blessing in society separation of church
and state you're referring to it so
basically yeah let me do this before we
get into this topic about fatherlessness
homes folks uh if you've been following
uh the the sponsorships lately we have
teamed up with goldco this took a couple
years for us to decide to do this with
what's going on today in the economy
being the fact that it's strange times
I'm talking to my Morgan Stanley guys or
my Goldman Sachs guys both sides no
matter who you talk to are not too
confident about what's going to happen
in 2023 I myself for years have always
had physical gold stored in different
places just to hedge this is not 50 your
portfolio you're 25 of your portfolio
but a small percentage of your portfolio
that you ought to consider having some
gold in the company that we decided to
team up with is gold code they've been a
six-time Inc 5000 winner 2022 company of
the Year thousands of five star reviews
and over a billion dollars in golden
silver placed value timing viewers can
get up to ten thousand dollars on free
silver and a free ounce of silver Ronald
Reagan coin with a qualified order
called them today at
855-594-2758 again eight five five nine
four two seven five eight or go to
goldco.com forward slash pbd once again
goldco.com forward slash pbd the Link's
gonna be in the description and in the
chat so here's a question for you for
fatherlessness stats I saw this the
other day and I speak on the salon and I
think a part of
what's going on today with the momentum
of Tate and with the momentum of you
know what you've been speaking about
with Prager University on the role
family nucleus you're seeing this being
talked about everywhere I see the stat
and I want to know how we got here and
how we need to fix this okay so here are
the stats the U.S has the highest rate
of children living in single-parent
households of Any Nation about 80
percent of single parent homes are led
by single mothers at a rate of 20 23
percent of children living with one
parent and no other adult the United
States is three times the world average
of seven percent so 23 percent is U.S
seven percent is World average China's
three percent India's four percent okay
where a mom isn't there or that isn't
there even for children with a father
present in the home the average school
age boy only spends about 30 minutes per
week
in one-on-one conversations with his
father for comparison the same boy on
average will spend about 44 hours per
week watching television playing video
games and surfing the internet ninety
percent of all homelessness and runaway
children 63 percent of teen suicide 85
percent of children and teens with
behavioral disorders come from
fatherless homes fatherlessness likewise
has a direct link to teen pregnancy and
sexual activity roughly 70 percent of
teenage pregnancies come from women
raised in fatherless homes and these
times these same women have
significantly higher abortion rates than
women raised by both a father and a
mother on the whole fatherless kids are
20 times more likely to be incarcerated
and 11 times more likely to exhibit
violent Behavior than children of two
parent households if a man and a wife
this one's one of the most interesting
stats if a man and a wife raise a child
they're less likely to end up in jail
but
they have the same chance as children
raised by just their fathers let me read
that one more time if a man and a wife
raise a child they're less likely to end
up in jail but they have the same
chances as children raised by just only
their fathers girls with no fathers have
low self-esteem and obviously this ties
to Crime mental issues economy suicide
rates all these other things one how did
we get here okay was this intentional to
want to break the family nucleus word
this is not a Leader's bulletin we want
to be winning in like this is not
something to be bragging about we're
we're a very competitive Nation we want
to be the best at Innovation we want to
be the best in this and that this is not
a place to brag about how do we get here
and Dennis what's the solution
one of the ways we got here was the
feminist movement
one of its mottos was a woman without a
man is like a fish without a bicycle
very famous phrase from early feminism
in the 60s 70s
men are essentially regarded as useless
we need we need their sperm and other
than that we really don't need men kids
don't need men I I cite in something I
wrote a New York Times survey of experts
quote unquote which usually means
foolish people who know one thing
and uh the the whole heading was our our
fathers necessary it was actually a a
big column uh in the New York Times and
and repeatedly
that fathers are not necessary again the
secular intellectual is is generally a
stupid person
fathers are essential
everything you read proves it and yet we
we live in a world that denies the
obvious that's a good phrase for the
Modern Age the the denial of the obvious
girls without fathers in their lives are
far more promiscuous and you may say so
what
and the answer to the so what is well
there is a what the what is they get
more depressed they they get angrier
they're less they're less happy
and uh I am
I've written a book on happiness because
I consider happiness to be an extremely
important part of life the happy make
the world better the unhappy make it
worse happiness is a is a moral issue
not just an emotional issue
how did we get here we got here once
again thanks to secularism
religious homes are far more likely to
have a father in them
people are not willing to acknowledge
that the roots of Western Civilization
which are called judeo-christian when
you abolish the roots of a civilization
the trees fall down I mean I don't know
why that shouldn't be obvious what are
we going to supplant it with
and we have supplanted it with with
again foolish ideas
men are not necessary women don't need
them and children don't need them
and so the men got the message
and now what do we have seven million
able-bodied men young able-bodied men
who have taken themselves out of the
workplace
this is a tragedy for society it is a
tragedy for
uh for men and it's a tragedy for women
looking for a good man to marry
it's also part of the uh another secular
idiocy of the left and that is that you
don't need to marry
this is uh this is an old-fashioned idea
that people should marry
three generations of women starting with
with the Baby Boomers of which I am a
member were taught uh yeah you want to
get married get married but young woman
the thing that will bring you the
greatest joy and happiness and
fulfillment is career which is one of
the greatest lies uh in in the world of
Lies
it's it's it's really as much a lie as
men give birth
but
when you hear something enough you start
to believe it oh I don't I don't really
need marriage I'll be great with a
career
I've written over a thousand columns
they're all on the internet 20 years
about 50 a year
and only one of them I didn't write
all I did was transcribe a call to my
radio show
and I have a male female hour every week
and I discuss this issue tell me if you
pursued career and not marriage has it
worked out for you
50-year-old woman who was a CEO makes a
good living
she has three degrees from universities
and essentially
almost in tears
spoke eloquently about how being a CEO
doesn't quite compensate for going home
to an empty home
when she sees friends with a husband and
children and everybody knows marriages
have issues and children are issues
but the purpose of life is not to avoid
issues it's to embrace the fullness of
life
and and I'll just say Point Blank
because nobody nobody tells people
things they don't want to hear everybody
wants to be loved I have no such aim
and uh you don't grow up if you don't
get married this is a message to men
this is a message to women
you can be very successful uh you don't
grow up okay you can be a wonderful
human being good volunteer services you
can you know you can adopt the Stray
puppies and and do all sorts of things
you every married person including
people who married and had a lousy
marriage and divorced
will acknowledge they grew up when they
got married and then you grow up
exponentially when you have children and
you're married but people don't want to
grow up the left is Peter Pan the left
is the embracing of immaturity
and you have the most professors are
immature people
and they they help develop immature
young people
it is a catastrophe they don't hear from
people like me obviously they do I mean
I I let me let me make this they don't
hear from people like me meaning that
we're not their professors we try to go
around it with prageru with lectures
with books and and not just me thank God
there are other wonderful people giving
good messages uh but uh we're censored I
mean and Ben Shapiro went to Berkeley
and they had 600 000 in security there's
no security for the most radical leftist
speaker they don't need one bodyguard
why do conservatives need six hundred
thousand dollars of security
do people not put two and two together
the damage the left does all it does is
destroy the American Medical Association
has announced that
the sex of a child should not be on a
birth certificate because we don't know
it until they choose it this is the
American Medical Association can you
pull this up yes pull it up
the American yes the American see this
is the this is the thing people don't
know the damage the left does to
everything it touches art music
education children male female relations
and Medicine it has corrupted the
medical field the American Society of
American Academy of Pediatrics or
pediatricians whatever the full name is
they've come out for affirmative care to
give miners uh uh hormone blockers
I mean that is evil you want yes that's
a new evil you asked for a new evil what
we're doing to kids now in the name of
trans uh of of of of transgender is pure
evil
you know Dennis you talked about
happiness and the book you're
referencing for people that are
listening he was referencing his book
happiness is a serious problem which if
you haven't read it read it he's not on
a book tour this was written many many
years ago but the truths that are in
there about finding purpose and the
things that you do and that the pursuit
of happiness is not the pursuit of joy
you know Joy is deeper in your heart
happiness is hey my team won today it
was a pretty good day and if all you're
searching for is those
those moments of Happiness that's that's
not Joy it's the deeper Joy about
service and what you do and purpose in
life and thank you for writing that book
Thank You Chuck Colson the late Chuck
Coulson wrote how now shall we live
Wonderful book you're probably familiar
with
and he was talking about the steps out
what do you think are some of the steps
out because you've very eloquently comes
out of what you're what you're talking
about here what initial steps out you
know as a society as people or as a
country you you talk about the left very
eloquently what are our initials oh I'll
I'll give you uh a terrific first step
to know that you have to fight your
nature you can't develop as a human
being you can't even be a happy human
being if you don't fight your nature
that's the number one issue in life
unpack then okay first of all
uh human nature is not basically good uh
only the naive who live who have lived a
spoiled life believe the nonsense that
human nature is basically good I don't
say human nature is basically evil I'm
saying it's not basically good you uh
number two your own nature there are two
Natures we have we all have human nature
and we all have our own Natures you have
to battle both my father told me all of
my childhood I'm lazy
I didn't like hearing it thank God he
said it to me my father my father
criticized me way more than he praised
me and I'm a better man for that fact
much better there's no comparison and uh
because
I that's not the role the role of a
parent
in the the world of the of the stupid in
which we live is to give kids
self-esteem so you give them trophies
for playing not trophies for winning
trophies for playing that's damaging to
children
you don't think you have to achieve in
in order to get a reward from society
well you do kid you have to achieve if
you didn't win you don't get a trophy
end of issue
so the first thing people call my show
and they go Dennis you're a father
figure to me I'm having a kid give me a
piece of advice and I always have the
same
give them teach them self-control not
self-esteem you get self-esteem from
self-control
self-control is the route to self-esteem
it is the route to happiness it is the
root to a productive it is the the root
the only route to a good life your words
carry a lot of weight so I want to I
want to unpack what you just said right
there will your father give you by the
way the same thing you're you're lazy
you're lazy or lazy that's the one thing
my dad kept telling me when I was a kid
so it's very common to what my dad told
me as a kid I read this book called the
Genius in all of us 15 years ago 14
years ago and maybe 10 years ago in the
statistic it showed in there it said
they're in the three different classes
of parents lower class middle class
upper class okay so lower middle upper
lower class from from the day the kid is
born to 18 they are uh uh they get
Negative affirmations means nose and
rejections 600 times 600 000 times more
than positive lower class middle was a
hundred thousand more negative
affirmative Nation okay then positive
and the upper class parents to their
kids was a hundred thousand more than
criticism makes sense that's what this
book is talking about the genius and
I'll achieve the more you were
criticized is that what you're no the
parents of the parents of the upper
class parents the way they spoke to
their kids is what she did was wrong but
I believe you can improve this dot dot
versus the lower class parents would say
you're an idiot you're a [ __ ] why'd you
do that so today my father was right I
was lazy calling a kid an idiot or a
[ __ ] is not helpful that's what I mean
you can't overcome being an idiot or a
[ __ ] I mean that that's the parent is
an idiot and a moral I agree it says
that yes so I'm not advocating that I
know you're not I'm I'm advocating the
opposite though of what we're doing oh
you're terrific oh my God you made a
bowel movement I I gotta get you a prize
that is the most beautiful poop I have
ever seen in my life or it's America's
favorite word it was an awesome poop oh
my God I mean so it never ends the
constant praise it doesn't mean anything
or or you become a narcissist you expect
that praise
there's got to be a balance parents
should be real you did a good job good
I I commend you a good job you did a bad
job you did a bad job
my wife who I I think she was a single
mom and she sort of uh uh is it is an
outlier because she raised a kid two
wonderful boys
and I'm saying because she's my wife
it's just a fact you meant she's a
lawyer well she she
is a lawyer but she doesn't practice for
sure yes yeah anyway she so she told her
kids as follows and I hope I get it
right and she's she's listening right
now
sure she's a little worried but
basically
if you uh if you do something wrong if
you're guilty and the police pick you up
don't waste your one phone call on me
hmm
that that was a very direct statement to
kids uh you use drugs that night you
don't sleep in my house
I that that's that's good stuff I asked
on my radio show my radio show has been
my human laboratory because I not only
talked two millions I talk with tens of
thousands with that's an amazing thing
to say
and I've learned an immense amount so I
often just ask questions if you didn't
use drugs in high school why didn't you
and I had no idea what the answers would
be virtually every single question isn't
it what a great question so right so
here was the answer
overwhelmingly they all said the same
thing men and women my mother would kill
me
specifically the mother the yes isn't
that interesting mother would kill yes
my mother would kill me not the father
well the the Assumption in a two-parent
home is if you get by your mother your
father will torture you you know I don't
know what's worse than killing you but
uh you know she's the first line of
defense you you know once I kill you
he'll dismember you I don't know but but
yes she's the first line of defense yeah
gotcha well yesterday I was playing
football with my nephew right I don't
have kids I'm working on it
um uh but I I take an active role in my
nephew's life and I he's the only child
and I I see that he's sort of been
coddled a little bit and it's kind of my
job as the uncle to be like toughen up
kid and every time I said every time you
catch the ball we have to catch it throw
it back and forth 10 times if you you
know then we move on to the next lesson
and every time he dropped it was an
excuse oh it's slippery outside oh the
sun's in my eye oh it's muddy whatever
it is I'm like listen if the ball hits
your hand you gotta catch a kid that's
the bottom line here right I played
football that's my thing at the hit your
hand you got to catch it my question to
you is this uh I said once you we're
done with this you'll get a reward for
for actually doing well if you don't do
good today you get nothing so he's he's
negotiating well can I get this can I
get that you talked about the trophy
culture and everybody gets something if
for the for the young parents out there
who are raising kids how should what
give me some case examples like if they
screw up
how should you address it and if they do
well how should you address it
so it depends what the screw-up means if
the screw-up is a moral screw-up which
is the only ones I am really concerned
with uh then they need to be punished uh
I I here's another message in addition
to the you you have to control you have
to fight your nature most important
message of all but I I had uh I had
another message to my kids I which is
almost unheard of for a Jewish upper
middle class parent it's almost unheard
of but I said to my kids repeatedly I
don't care about your grades
which is almost unheard of I've heard I
know
among my peers they they found it almost
unbelievable that I did this all I care
about is your character
okay so I don't I don't care about your
grades all I care about is your
character
and uh I think I have two good kids on
one went through a very difficult time
uh he he one of my kids is biological
one one of my kids is adopted for a day
from the day of birth he was born to a
meth addict mother I did not know that
at the time and that that played havoc
in his early life as it turns out he's
terrific today he's married he wants to
make a family he's he's he I I thank God
for him my older son was was never a a
difficult issue uh and uh but uh that
was my message to them character is is
all that matters to me and if I if I if
I heard that they cheated on a test or
uh that they were uh gratuitously uh
mean to a kid or whatever whatever
character flaw then I came down on them
uh if they if they didn't get good
grades I didn't care I didn't care if
they went to college I didn't care what
college they went to I I most colleges
are despicable places today despicable
they teach sick doctrines
babies teach babies at our universities
if I hear you're a professor of gender
studies I assume you're a fool if I hear
you're an epidemiologist I assume you're
a fool do you know what epidemiologists
did to the world with the lockdowns do
you know the damage they did to kids
epidemiologists telling Public Health
officials telling people to keep schools
closed for two years when kids had very
essentially no danger from covid do you
know the damage that the these so-called
experts did to kids why aren't parents
angry at these people why do they still
believe in quote-unquote experts
Sweden closed down nothing it has the
lowest excess death rate of the last two
years on Earth
no kid got covered and they kept the
schools open until the age of 16.
Sweden shamed the rest of the world in
staying open thank God for Sweden it was
our it was our litmus test
people it is very hard it's hard for me
I went to Columbia University graduate
school and and I remember if you were a
professor of History I almost shook
because I thought wow what a I'm meeting
someone who has mastered
such a great discipline of history or
professor of English or whatever
but now if I hear you a professor I
assume you're a fool not all professors
are full I just make that assumption wow
Guilty By Association no not by
association by Title by profession it's
not because they're associating with
other fools do you know that uh I think
her name is Amy wax a professor at
University of Pennsylvania Law School
ivy league law school she wrote a column
with another professor saying you know
what middle class Bourgeois values are
great values basically as follows uh
that you uh you graduate high school you
get a job you get married and then have
children after you get married those are
the four things and you'll be a winner
in this Society basically if you just do
those four things
just for writing that 250 law professors
at the University of Pennsylvania asked
the university to not allow her to teach
the introductory course she was teaching
she's been ostracized by fellow lawyers
because all she affirmed was middle
class values which they call now of
course white supremacist values which of
course is an insult to non-whites oh I
see only whites should graduate high
school get a job get married and then
have children blacks should not do that
the only systemic racism in America is
from the left they believe in separate
graduations for blacks separate
dormitories for blacks they believe that
it is wrong to be race blind they
believe race tells me something about
you so I have a great question if race
is important what do you know about a
person if you know he or she is black
maybe one thing you know about that
person
after all it's supposedly a very
important aspect the most important
aspect according to the morons who teach
at colleges
you know maybe nothing nothing
you know nothing if you know someone is
white you know nothing if someone is
anything right it means nothing
okay yesterday yes Emily exactly
skin colors is is less important than
shoe color
if your shoes don't match your outfit
especially for a woman it matters
yeah but your your skin color doesn't
mean a damn thing how do you judge
character though like you back to your
question about your the point you made
about your kids about how Character
Matters more than their grades we had
the conversation with Neil deGrasse
Tyson a week ago about how you measure
success grades and what it was like how
you can uh bounce back from failure you
know your ability to associate with
people in your class a multitude of
reasons of how you can predict success
right the predictors of success but
character you know moral fiber how do
you like if you're raising one of your
kids how do you grade that it's easy to
say oh you got a 1600 on your SATs you
get a 4.0 great kid you know you were
president of your class these are
accolades you can actually tangibly
assess well there are many ways there
there are many ways so not an order of
importance but the first one that comes
to my mind is are they are they truth
tellers
lying is the is the mother of evil
all evil emanates from lies that's why
I'm so afraid of the left because their
truth is not a left-wing value it's a
liberal value and it is a conservative
value but it's not a left-wing value
so uh are do they lie that's a big one
another one is I watch I watch how they
behave how do they treat a stranger
do they try to make people who enter
their life feel good
are they warm to the stranger to to some
somebody who comes to the house if if
they if if they meet an autistic kid do
they spend a little time trying to talk
to that kid I mean there are so many
indicators in the course of a day
whether you're a narcissist do they only
talk about themselves do they do they
ask questions about people that they
meet uh uh it's
your question actually
uh is something I mean I should write a
a piece on I I just I thank you for that
because I I have sort of uh
I'm deeply involved in music so I always
think in terms of music I conduct
orchestras as an avocation
and I don't have Perfect Pitch Perfect
Pitch means that if you hear a C sharp
you know it's C sharp I it's it you
either have it or you don't it's a gift
I have a I I have sort of a gift and I
don't take credit for it it is a gift
I I I I I don't know how smart people
are immediately because I don't give a
damn how smart they are
uh uh but I do know I I'm a pretty good
measurer of a person's decency
there there are little things that that
I I see in people in in interactions and
I I don't always have Clues but I often
do but if if you don't have the gift it
has to be written out
so uh I'm gonna do that but watching for
example I I always tell the the example
if you're on a date
don't don't watch how the day treats you
they're going to treat you fine because
they want something
watch how they treat the waiter
that that to me is really important
how do you treat how you treat your boss
is not an indication how you treat the
janitor
is an indication
when I see people where I work at my
radio station in Los Angeles when I see
people talk to the janitor so how's your
day Jose how's your day Joe whatever it
is
that they even know their name
that that's a big sign to me
so there there are indications and uh
another biggie
you can't be a good person if you're not
grateful one of the reasons I loathe the
left is because the left teaches you to
be ungrateful in gratitude is the is the
deepest component of leftism
the the most obvious is they're not
grateful to be American
ingratitude and entitled the same thing
does it have the similar meeting there's
they're very related because yes cousins
that's right uh
every grateful person is a good person
every ungrate ungrateful person is a bad
person it is it is the it's the the
golden root to decency so you should
teach your child to be grateful that's
why saying thank you was so critical
and how many by the way talking about
human nature if human nature were good
how many times would you have to tell
you your kids say thank you five
but how many times is it the average
parent say say thank you ten thousand
why didn't they get it on the third time
if they're basically good
how much of the characters nature versus
nurture meaning like my mother Jewish
mother she's like Adam I don't get what
you do you just better be the best at it
and you better treat the janitor the
same as the CEO these are things I've
heard my entire life like Tom has two
daughters very well-behaved girls Pat's
got four kids mostly well behaved but
the one thing I will say is he's taught
them do not lie for sure right read your
books do not lie reward mechanisms uh
how much is nature versus nurture like
your parenting and you're up right so
with the nature versus nurture thing I
have a uh a funny answer
nature is one hundred percent and
nurture is one hundred percent it's all
the above is there there's so
they're so they're both so critical
you can't control nature though you can
control nurture well you can control
nature how do you do that by fighting it
I was lazy so what did I do uh I decided
I I figured a way around it I can't
change the fact that I rather play than
work it's just a fact okay I know that
so could every kid though right every
kid right well but I'm not a kid anymore
at least chronologically I still am a
kid but not chronologically so what did
I do I took on so many obligations I had
no choice right I mean I'm I'm on your
show I had to get up at 3 30 Pacific
time to get here for this show that's
not my favorite time to wait awaken but
I took the obligation to be on your show
I couldn't call you go you know I'm
really a Patrick I really feel bad I I'm
still on California at the time yeah
exactly so uh my way I so I'm given the
fact that I rather play than work so I
took on so many projects you know so
rather work than play you mean uh no I'd
rather play them oh you would rather yes
of course yes so what I did was I took
on all these obligations I have no
choice so I you'll get a kick out of
this so the biggest project of my life
aside from prageru and the radio and the
column and all that the biggest is this
five volume commentary on the tour of
the first five books of the Bible it's
called the rational Bible it's the
best-selling commentary on the Bible in
America today I am proud to say because
if you don't know if if you do know the
insights of the Bible you will be a
happier and better human being uh these
are life-changing books if people look
up the rational Bible three volumes of
the five are out Genesis Exodus
Deuteronomy and I have no problem
pushing it nobody writes Bible
commentaries to get to get rich okay
let's be let's be honest okay so
especially the latest Deuteronomy okay I
mean you know oh my God a guy's gonna
make a fortune he wrote a Deuteronomy
commentary uh but uh but if you read the
the Amazon reviews
they it's it does change lives and uh I
I get the I get these insights uh from
them from these books and I try to share
them uh in in the writing of this so why
did I mention this aside from that I
wanted to mention it
so when the Deuteronomy was the last one
it's I'm not going in order
it's the fifth of the five books so I
got the I got the copy of Deuteronomy in
the mail two years ago
and it came out last just a few months
ago and I got it in the mail and I look
at it now you most people would think
with all that work and you see and
that's beautifully printed by the way
the publisher did a gorgeous job
and I look at it you would think I would
think wow
that is I'm really proud of myself or
something like that right I lit I give
you my word of Honor I this the only
reaction I had was I looked at it
and I said when did I write that
I just couldn't believe I had the time
that the the Marvel to me was not the
book and all all of the wonderful things
of seeing your own book
it was wow when did I write that I just
powerful but and the answer is I had no
choice
the the the publisher expects a book
from me
so that's so when you of course you can
fight your nature
that's that's exactly of course
otherwise we're doomed such a simple
concept for anybody to apply especially
if you have a reputation of being lazy
keep a busy calendar and commitments
that you have to come through because
you don't want to let people down that's
right get busy that's exactly right that
you you you got it well you always get
it that's why I love talking to you you
you to your credit now I'm interviewed a
lot you really listen
a lot of a lot of people who interview
they have a list of questions and it's
clear to me I could say in in the middle
you know I pooped really well yesterday
and they would then have their amazing
that implied that they listened they no
amazing dentists would be at least they
listened my point is to go to the next
question all right yes so what's the key
to success they just kind of go to the
next one but Dennis let's go to uh this
other topic with the last 30 minutes
that we have together and as soon as
outside as well you guys got to drive uh
the Declassified documents that have
been found the classified documents have
been found okay with Joe Biden and it's
so interesting with the more and more
we're learning more things are coming
out the timing of Trumps the timing of
his they knew about it right before
midterms but they held it back till now
what are your thoughts about what's
going on here there's you know a lot of
people I listen to Dan bongino yesterday
Dan bongino is saying there's no way in
the world
the Biden Administration is going to
find documents like this and say let's
turn it in because we have to be honest
he says you have to be a fool to believe
they gave it up to the lawyers he says
the only way the story is true is
somebody on the inside either set him up
or knew was there and found it because
they are trying to do something to him
now whether that's true or not I don't
know what do you think about what's
going on with these classified documents
I don't have better insights than others
into a lot of this political stuff I
have my insights are the big picture
the big picture is that
and I say this I I I really I have to
suppress tears because I so love this
country
but I love truth more than I love the
country
and the truth is we are as corrupt as as
a third world Banana Republican in
Central America
this is a corrupt country the left has
made it corrupt I know people say Trump
Trump trump Trump trump Trump trump and
is their way of of of
masking the truth of the corruption 51
heads of intelligence agencies signed a
letter a few weeks before the 2020
election
saying that the hunter Biden laptop was
Russian disinformation
they all lied every single one in other
words the entire intelligence apparatus
of America is as corrupt as it is in
Guatemala or Brazil or or Iran
not as evil necessarily they don't kill
as many people as the Iranians but but
there is corrupt they're just they lie
they lie on behalf of the left just like
Prophet that lied on behalf of the
Communist Party in the Soviet Union uh
we the the media lie on behalf of the
left and the Democratic Party in the
United States I mean that most Americans
don't know the level of corruption is
only because it's censored how many
Americans every conservative American
who who listens to anything uh uh like
talk radio or or reads any conservative
news source knows that 51 heads of
intelligence signed a lying letter to
enable uh a Biden to win
but I don't think two percent
of Americans liberal or left know that
the 51 signed that letter
so uh anything is possible with regard
to why this is now coming out uh but
what what will be interesting is that
they want to prosecute uh Donald Trump
for it will they prosecute Joe Biden for
it and by the way maybe they will in
which case maybe the most nefarious uh
scenario is they just want to get rid of
the guy because they know he can't win
the next election and they don't want
him to run I I don't know I'm not even
saying that all I want to know is will
all of the condemnations of Donald Trump
for unclassified documents in Mar-A-Lago
be leveled at Joe Biden for unclassified
documents in his garage that that's
that's the uh or excuse me for not
unclassified classified documents in his
garage
uh
look how many how many Americans know
the truth about so much if you don't
know how many people are dying see this
is a classic example of the left if you
point out how many young people are
dying like athletes just dropping dead
on the field and and I see reports like
this regularly I mean regularly like at
least every week and this is just what
we know of and then you say well
shouldn't we just investigate whether
the vaccine has been beneficial or
harmful to young people young meaning
under 50. that's a pretty large young
group shouldn't we just investigate oh
you're an anti-vaxxer all my children
are completely vaccinated by the way I'm
not sure that I would now do that they
talking about lying and what the left
has done to Medicine
that in you know that in California now
as as of last week in California a
doctor who says things that the AMA or
the or the California medical
association differ with can lose his or
her license to practice medicine doctors
are not free in California to speak out
on medical issues if if Pfizer that's
really what it means if Pfizer doesn't
agree with them I I mean the the level
of corruption
masking kids at two years of age first
of all I think you're an idiot if you
mask yourself at 52 years of age but
that that's that's that is beside the
point but a two-year-old
we have hurt children and the and the
the children's hospitals that that allow
surgeons to remove healthy girls breasts
if they say they're boys
did you hear the latest story it was
just what was it yesterday I reported
where was it outside of San Diego
uh a um in the the girls locker room a a
a a male shows his genitalia in the
showers the 17 year old says you know I
don't I don't want to see I don't want
to see it I don't want my little sister
to see this
but they say sorry this was at the YMCA
once called the Young Men's children
Association did you get you got it you
guys are fast 17 year old scolded for
crying over transgender woman's penis at
YMCA look she's she's scolded this 17
year old is scolded this is the girl
speaking yes this is the girl speaking
that's exactly right
it was changing after swimming one day
last month at the Santee YMCA when she
spotted a naked trans woman in the
changing rooms
so here's the story you get it this is
the sick World we're living if you show
your penis to young girls you are
arrested but if you show your penis to
young girls and say you're a female
you're rewarded
and protected clown World protected
rewarded uh and and the and the girl who
objects is the one who's punished so let
me let me ask you're intolerant that's
right let me let me ask this question so
to me logically
that that can't make sense to anybody
right logically so so Dennis how much of
this creating momentum has to do that
the one percent are so much louder than
the other 99 who are just saying it's
not a big deal let it go well what you
have is the usual phenomenon cowardice
is the human Norm again human nature is
not basically good most people including
me our nature is to be a coward
I've had to fight that and I'm not I'm
not a coward that that I can say
categorically uh but you have to fight
it the natural inclination in life is to
be afraid afraid of of being disliked
afraid of being ostracized afraid of
being fired afraid of being shut down
afraid of whatever it is that's one of
another reason why uh the only answer to
all of this is the judeo-christian code
which says you fear God you don't fear
man
the the only out in not fearing human
beings is essentially fearing God and
it's it's a basic uh biblical principle
but uh that's what it is
people are afraid uh to uh to why do the
girls at the University of Pennsylvania
a swim team why did they continue to
compete when the when this guy who said
he's a girl uh went from male swimming
where he was a nothing to female
swimming where he was a champion he
deprived all these girls of of winning
uh races uh because he said he was a
girl
and uh and every one of the girls had to
go along with this knowing they were
being cheated uh by by a man who says
he's a woman they were cheated the guys
that cheat or the woman's a cheat code
or whatever call him her whatever you
want is a cheat and the New York Times
supports cheating the New York Times The
Washington Post CNN they they're they
are morally awful uh uh uh vehicles for
lying to the public and so here is the
question why did the girls compete if
every girl on the team said were not
racing it would have ended this fraud of
having men compete in women's sports
but they won't they're afraid because if
they do that the University of
Pennsylvania threatened them
they you know we will come down they may
have been evicted from the University
but they wouldn't have kicked out a
whole team but the girls understandably
were afraid they'll be called
transphobes you don't want to be called
a transphobe right of course not New
York Times will call you a transphobe if
the girls decided not to race the New
York Times that sick editorial page of
the New York Times would have said
they're transphobic girls
which label right now is the is is the
biggest career ending label one can get
a racist homophobe transphob I mean by
the way do you ever notice isn't it
interesting there's a word for Jew
hatred anti-Semitism there's a word for
Muslim hatred islamophobe why isn't
there a word for Christian hatred
because the left makes up our vocabulary
the most hated group the most hated
religious group on Earth today are
Christians they're certainly the most
killed and I'm a Jew saying this
there's no word for nobody hates
Christians uh if you show a picture of
Muhammad a painting of Muhammad not a
cartoon a Muslim painting of Muhammad
just done in Hamlin University looked
that one up h-a-m-l-i-n-e for the the
art Professor who taught the corset I'm
telling you in advance I'm putting up a
an ancient uh rendition of Muhammad if
if you are offended by it you may not
want to watch and she was kicked out of
Hamlin University she's an art professor
she showed she showed the piece or
Charlie oh wait but but yeah or well
that that was that they were murdered
yes so yeah there it is Hamlin is fired
over medieval painting done by Muslims
you can't show a Muslim painting of zoom
in for the picture so we can see what
the picture is yeah there it is well
this is because thou shall not create
any caricature painting or image yeah
but that's not in the Quran that's that
some Muslims believe that later Muslims
they obviously medieval Muslims didn't
believe that they did make paintings of
of Muhammad but anyway
crucifix my own the reason I raise it
there is there there's a famous uh
quote-unquote artwork piss Christ
which toward put that one up oh yeah
that that toward the American museums
it's a jar of urine with this the guy
a a crucifix in his own urine and it
went all around the country did
nobody's afraid of Christians The Book
of Mormon it's a book of Broadway
nobody's afraid of Mormons of course
that they're afraid of Muslims because
cowardice is a central tenet of of
leftism back to Pat's question of what's
what is the worst label to have is there
one that's worse than no no
anti-semitic with Kanye that's that's
obviously
they're they're all tied for first
however they can dismiss you they'll
they'll uh they'll just use the term I
don't know why why I used to be racist
though right if you were able to racist
or yeah you were done right but every
white is racist so therefore there's no
such thing as racism as soon as you say
every you have ended the issue
that's right it's but by the way it's
such a joke
here I am I'm I'm your I'm the uh Dei uh
head at the University diversity equity
and inclusion and I'm telling you every
white is racist
so obviously they're speaking
autobiographically are they not hello
I'm a racist and you should trust me
I don't quite follow that anyway it's
just that's another great lie for the
record I don't have a racist bone in my
body I don't give a damn about your
color
simple as that
but but that is now called racist did
you know look up that you you University
of California list of microaggressions
if you say colorblind you're a racist
colorblind is a racist
yes
if you say there is only one race the
human race that is considered racist by
the University of California you were
how old when MLK was there color
blindness so I would have been uh what
was that 68 yeah yeah so I've been 19
years old yeah yeah
everything he I assume that was when
you're going through a major situation
in your life you're in college you're
learning you're seeing well no all these
assassinations were I I I I didn't
understand what was happening to my
beloved America I I have to admit it was
it was disconcerting obviously
prior to 1960 was 1968 when MLK was shot
and Bobby Kennedy was at the worst year
that you can remember or is it even
worse now the worst year was 2020 with
coveted lockdowns not just the lockdown
the riots
worse than Nike well over a lie the uh
George Floyd was not killed because he
was black
it's just a lie it's another left-wing
lie if it's not a lie then I I must
retire from public life but if it is a
Lie the New York Times should go out of
business one of us is lying to the
public either he was killed because he's
black or he wasn't killed because he's
black however I have big evidence and
that is that the Attorney General of
Minnesota
uh uh whose name eludes me for a moment
but he he is a big he's a black and he's
a man of the left and he did not charge
Derek Chauvin with racism this was not a
hate crime because he had zero evidence
that it had anything to do with George
Floyd being black the entire year of
riots and protests was based on a lie
Keith Ellison
that's correct Keith Ellison
that's right and and you listen this is
two years ago two and a half years ago
so we've spoken about as God knows how
many times what was the outcome you know
the whole uh saying never uh missed the
opportunity of a crisis who said that
Rahm Emanuel somebody yes so it was to
use that crisis to eliminate a man is
that kind of what it was to use that
crisis to get part of the guy but it
owes also to use that crisis
to to undo American history
uh Donald Trump was absolutely right in
predicting you know they're going after
the the Confederates uh uh today they're
going to go after George Washington and
Abraham Lincoln tomorrow that's exactly
what happened
the Erasure of of America's Noble
history by the way you shouldn't I don't
know if we should even erase the ignoble
history
Peter Stuyvesant the the Dutchman who
who ruled or governed New York before it
became New York it was New Amsterdam
first every every Jew who knows history
knows he was knows he was an anti-semite
I would not be for the removal of a
Peter Stuyvesant uh sculpture
uh
I listened to Wagner operas Wagner hated
Jews Wagner was it was it was a crackpot
anti-semite but he wrote gorgeous music
I listened to Wagner
I mean once you start it never ends and
it doesn't end that is exactly the point
what is it there's a famous statement of
Soviet dissidents in the Soviet Union
uh the future is known it is the past
that is always changing that's what's
happening in America the past is always
changing according to the New York Times
we were founded in 1619
I mean it's it's up there with men give
birth
but uh the the 2020 was so sad to me
because I realized
the the ease with which you can
brainwash a civilization I always
thought my field of study was communism
at the Russian Institute of Columbia
University
been spent a lot of time in communist
countries I always thought that you can
only brainwash a population in a tyranny
and this was a revelation to me you can
brainwash a population in a free country
then as as a Jew yourself when you saw
what was going on with Kanye and the
things he was saying and boom Adidas
and his marriage and you know everything
you listen to his comments about Hitler
on Alex Jones and now he's been kind of
low-key for the last six weeks which I
think is a great idea the fact whoever
he listened to good for him for to kind
of taking a break and apparently Loki he
got married to somebody that no one
knows about it was done in a very low
key way now I don't know if this is true
or not it's just what the media is
saying how did you how did you process
what he was saying uh about Jews were
you upset were you frustrated were you
saying well partially he's right about
this well he's not right about this I
can't believe he said that What feelings
did you give when he was saying what he
was saying
well I don't I don't work on feelings uh
as much I try to think through
rationally
I wrote a book on anti-Semitism I have
fought It All of My Life the book is
called why the Jews
and
there there's every every population has
a percentage of people who hate Jews
they they're a whole host of reasons why
people might hate Jews and
as I point out in my book and then the
piece I wrote on Kanye West well my
columns
non-jews need to know something
anti-Semitism destroys societies I'm not
saying it because I'm a Jew I'm saying
it because it's true
no Society has survived anti-semitism
Spain was one of the greatest world
powers than it had the Spanish
Inquisition and the Spanish expulsion of
the Jews in 1492 and have you heard from
Spain in the last 500 years
it went downhill the speed it was speed
of a skier after it kicked out its Jews
Germany was was the most vibrant culture
in Europe
uh before Hitler
the most vibrant in in in the Arts in in
philosophy in science
and then they had the Holocaust what do
you hear from Germany Volkswagen
I mean what what the economy is can
people even name a living German
it's not to mention what was done to
Germany as a result of Hitler being in
power the Germans the losses in Germany
the the rape of German women by Soviet
soldiers
it it is you're an idiot if you're a
non-jew and you don't fight
anti-semitism
I don't even care if people like Jews I
care if people hate Jews you don't like
Jews don't like Jews fine I I doesn't it
doesn't
everybody has a pet group that they may
not like okay the Germans didn't like
the polls the polls didn't like the
Russians the Russians don't like the
ukrainians everybody dislikes his
neighbor the British didn't like the
Irish the Irish didn't like the British
it doesn't mean a damn thing and
jokes I used to hear that were called
polish jokes when I went to England the
exact same jokes but it was the Irish
the exact same joke that was what was so
funny about it so I don't it's dislike
or don't like and hate they're a very
very big different thing if a man can
say
Hitler was a good man
he he is a sick poop he's a sick puppy I
mean there's just there's something very
scary about such a human being and by
the way
if you have to be a Jew to be offended
by that if somebody said Stalin was a
good person I would think the person is
a sick puppy too and it wasn't Jews who
Stalin went after mostly he killed six
million five million ukrainians
deliberately plus 30 million Russians in
general
but didn't how many Americans died
fighting Hitler isn't that an insult to
all the Americans who died in World War
II Oh Hitler oh really so these
Americans died in vain if Hitler was a
good guy then your grandparents who died
or fought they uh they died in vain they
fought in vain they got blinded and or
or shell-shocked in vain
uh but people don't have a they they
don't have either courage or a moral
compass to to distinguish between good
and bad so you don't like Jews you don't
like juice fine I'm not asking you it's
I as I said I'm repeating myself forgive
me but hating Jews is very bad thing
Dennis what's the difference between a
Jew saying there are still people who
hate Jews versus a black uh a person on
the left saying there are still people
who hate blacks yes there are people who
hate plaques that's correct
but uh so there were people who hate
every group
therefore what the question is how many
what percentage of whites in America
hate blacks it's tiny the percentage is
tight tiny okay uh uh what was it Larry
Elder who who you know he could reel off
these statistics uh if you woke him up
at 3 A.M uh he's he's gifted in that way
I'm not gifted in that way to no
statistics by heart but uh he shows how
many whites voted for Obama uh and you
know that what was it the percentage of
whites who voted for Obama was smaller
than the percentage of whites who voted
for some white candidate I don't
remember what it was uh this this is the
least racist multi-ethnic country on the
face of the Earth in the in the history
of the world here's a statistic no kid
at Harvard knows
okay at Harvard I'm picking the creme de
La Creme and that is that uh ask Ask a
kid at Harvard how many uh how many
slaves how many black slaves were
brought to the United States and the
transatlantic slave trade and then asked
them how many blacks came to the United
States voluntarily in the last 50 years
the first one is 360
000 the second number is three million
are they stupid by the way if America
systemically racist every black who
moves here is an idiot
you can't have it both ways and as I
always say any Jews moved to Germany in
the 1930s not one
right because that was systemically
racist
blacks moved to the United States
because it's the best country on Earth
for a black to live period and they know
it
only the left that denies it what was
the number again 360 and 3 million 360
000 versus 3 million that's correct and
uh you know I take a risk with any one
of these numbers because if it's wrong I
lose my reputation but I've been
broadcasting 40 years and Truth is my
number one goal those are the those are
the data
and you know where I got the data on the
3 million from William sapphire in the
New York Times in the 1980s
that's the amazing thing that's where I
got it last thing here a couple minutes
so
Holocaust you got uh slavery okay we're
not comparing two different tragedies so
that's not what we're going to be doing
we're not sending units of which is
Awards which is this I'm not doing that
I would uh by the way I believe in
gradations of evil slavery is Despicable
and evil but in the final analysis you
could at least live in the final
analysis the Jews were enslaves Jews
would have given their right arm to be
slaves they were exterminated there is a
difference and people need to know that
I do make moral distinctions if we don't
we lose our Humanity
so that's not the question I was going
to my question wasn't that my question
was going to be why after such a
dramatic event that happened to Jews
okay with the intentions of wanting to
eliminate every single Jew on the face
of the planet right right this is what
Hitler's Vision was right
why is it years later
after a crisis like that
what values and principles helped Jews
pretty much own Hollywood do well in
business do well in life oh I'll tell
you I have the answer go for it they
didn't see themselves as victims it is
the most paralyzing thing in Black life
what the left is doing to blacks the
left hates you blacks just you no they
don't hate you they have contempt for
you telling you you're a victim is
paralyzing Jews did not walk around
thinking their victims even after the
why not because they knew it is
completely self-destruct how did they
know I don't know it's a great well
maybe because of the Jewish tradition
has always been we take responsibility
for our own suffering so why wouldn't
the media try to Target the Jews to make
them feel victims
the media doesn't have contempt for Jews
it has content why not why not because
the left has contempt for blacks because
they use them they don't use Jews why
why can't they use Jews if they can use
anything they would do it so why can't
they use juices well Jews Jews are I
mean Jews are disproportionately on the
left I mean there's no way around it so
uh in effect there's no there's no need
to to keep they already have a business
yeah in a sense yes I got you I got you
interesting I'm sorry to say wow I don't
want to I don't want to hold you up let
me so first of all I I love being with
you which is why I woke up God knows
when the thing to get here I really do
you it's a joy to be with you and number
two I do want to just tell people if if
they are not familiar with my work I do
a weekly thing for prageru called the
the uh the fireside chat uh it's it's a
podcast every week at prageru.com and my
among my books is the rational Bible if
you are convinced there is no God and
religion is nonsense it is written for
you
there are three volumes pick anyone you
like we're gonna put the link to all of
it below we're going to continue with
the podcast so gang hang tight we're
going to go another 30 minutes because I
don't have my uh Zoom till 11 o'clock
but Dennis appreciate you for coming out
this was fantastic as usual every time
you come and you speak you give a
complete different perspective and this
was fantastic thank you so much yes
anytime anytime so if you want to walk
out you can walk out we're going to all
right we're going to continue though
again bye everybody just leaving the
podcast
character all right I look forward to
reading let's continue guys uh uh you
know I've had the privilege of speaking
to Dennis multiple times over the last
13 years every time this man speaks you
just get a complete different
perspective and as soon you're still
listening to this we love you you're
awesome have a great day I wish I could
see you but uh maybe next time uh so
let's get into it let's get into some of
these other things with you when you
heard about Tom with you as well when
you heard about the uh the classified
documents if you want to just move over
here when you heard about the classified
documents with uh Joe Biden how much of
this with Dan bongino's argument about
saying the fact that
there's no way and and here's a
perspective when I kind of put it into
context like think about your part of
Biden's Camp okay and you find
classified documents what do you do
imagine if your Reagan's Camp Clinton's
Camp Bush's Camp Trump's Camp any Camp
what do they do just assume what they're
going to be doing wouldn't they say hey
Mr President you got some classified
documents here can you please take these
studies out to the office or put in a
save that's not the place for it you
understand what I'm saying which is kind
of like sure can we just take this back
to the White House and not leave it here
it's just a very basic conversation like
if someone found it back in the day yeah
I like can you see the visual the car
backs up and your own campuses oh Mr
Biden President Biden you have that no
we have to report this to FBI or you
know it's a very confusing thing
to see that happening so what are your
thoughts about what's going on with the
document well look
you know I'm not a conspiracy theorist
you know but I just look at who's
speaking what are they saying and I
interpret it and right now there is what
you would call Friendly Fire coming in
um number one any rational advisor to
the president your personal attorney
whoever it is that notice this or the
people that were working with you at the
Penn Biden Institute where you clean out
the office and they're like hey in that
closet there was there some reference
documents in here that maybe need to go
back somewhere because you've got some
documents in here that appear to be
government stamped why are they still
here I mean someone would have cleaned
out you know the office someone because
apparently hasn't been there in four
years and there's stuff there so the
number of people that could have given a
good comment to the president is
significant there's probably a dozen or
more people that had Direct knowledge
that could have said hey maybe we should
call somebody get these things picked up
number one but number two look at where
this is coming from this is coming from
I mean Omar was on a talk show uh and
she brought it up and the talk show host
tried to go with the talking point and
defend Biden and she goes no no no this
is a significant thing I think it's I
think there's opportunist Friendly Fire
coming in that doesn't want Biden to be
the candidate you know you know what's
crazy uh for me the same thing with
Harry when I said why would you write a
book trash in your family and years
later you're going to have this backfire
on you and your kids are gonna write
something about you when you do this to
the opposing side you're gonna see
months after what they did to Trump
first time ever for that to happen to
trump it happens to you now uh uh it
backfires now Garland has to keep the
same standards or else he's seen as what
is seen as they're targeting a candidate
to eliminate a candidate which that's
definitely not going to be a good look
going into 2024. but wouldn't you think
they would be saying hey nothing to see
here nothing to see here Merrick just
chill nothing to see here that's usually
but you see the Playbook but they're not
yeah but they're not look at the look at
the Democrats that are out there that
said Merrick Garland has no choice and
they were saying this before Merrick
Garland says hey I'm thinking about it
it's been going on it's been going on
for a week you know that the number of
people is is escalating so you just ask
yourself a question why are so many
friends of Biden or shimmy why are so
many people that are on the team
that Democrat team why are they coming
out and saying Adam
yeah I think um one thing if you go back
and revisit that interview that Biden
did with uh I think it was 60 Minutes at
the time he's like how could you be this
irresponsible and that just kind of keep
playing in my head it's like all right
Joe do you want to answer that exact
same question to yourself there Chief so
um we'll see what happens here I mean
one thing I I will say is that
whether it's Trump whether it's Biden I
don't think anyone's going to have any
legal ramifications
video playing right now
you know Trump has the the is able to
kind of Duck and Cover under the fact
that he was president at the time Biden
is the current president I know although
this did happen as VP but I think Tom
brings up a good point
Democrats are looking for a soft Landing
to be like Joe thanks for your service
buddy you know the whole reason the
whole premise of why Joe Biden became
elected president whether you agree with
him or disagree with him was the fact
that he at least was had a decent moral
compass hey he's just he's you know good
old Joe
we don't know that but that's right
exactly marketability right he's not
Trump basically he's the anti-trump he's
been in Washington forever he's a good
guy you should trust Joe but slowly but
surely you know the the the larger the
lens the deeper the lens of being in the
Oval Office you realize what's all this
stuff you're crying going on what's this
Hunter bite her laptop thing going on
what are all these things that you
actually did that you were accusing
Trump of uh oh not so fast here so I
think Tom is right there there I think
there is a it's sort of a loud and proud
faction at this point since they got
through midterms it wasn't a red wave
that they're like hey Uncle Joe thanks
so much for everything you got the
orange man out of there you did a great
job you're going to be a one-term
president just like Jimmy Carter
time to hit the road PS you're 80
freaking 95 years old at this point
mentally thanks for your service you
know let's move on to 2024. so so you
know you know if this happens so here's
a question
uh who who will be the first female
president if there was a bet in Las
Vegas which I don't know if there is or
not let's search it to see if there is
I'm sure who will be the first female
president do you think it's going to be
a a meaning a Kamala Harris where he
gets ousted before finishing his term or
you think they're gonna let him finish
his term before Kamala be coming though
even if they try to impeach him just
just go down let's go down that road
because you said this is going to be the
year of Investigation sure we started
off the year with investigations voila
uh keep in mind the the Dems own the
Senate so even if the house tries to
impeach him like they did with uh Trump
multiple times Ukraine this that the
other Russia the Senate is not going to
vote to impeach Biden that's not going
to happen or it's not gonna they the
house might raise it but the Senate's
not going to pass it and I think it's
60. 60 yeah 63 or 60 some number like
that yeah they're not going to get it
send it out of 100 you're not even 50
you're saying no no it's not 50. correct
yeah no correct when you um when you put
a Supreme Court judge on I think it's 51
I think it's 60 of the Senate has to
vote for them back to your original
question I God forbid it we see and you
know barring anything out of nowhere I
don't see Kamala Harris what's more
what's more likely to happen let me just
ask this question is it more likely for
him to resign is it more likely for him
to finish his term okay and then say
yeah I'm not gonna run I'm gonna step
aside or is it more likely for him to
continuous term and run for 2024. what
is more likely out of those three things
I think the least likely of those three
things is him to step aside and just
like resign yeah I don't see him this
isn't a resignable offense agree
um so you agree with me thanks
um I don't know I think it's too early
to tell it wasn't a joke I think it's
too early to tell whether he's going to
run for 2024 or not he says he will but
is this the type of incident that will
pierce the armor so much to the fact
that he won't even want to run I doubt
it once you've been in politics this
long it's very hard to be like all right
Joe just give it up buddy I just I think
I think even on even on the uh clearly
on the right they want Joe out of there
but even on the left there's such a
yearning for a younger more attractive
candidate and look I'm no fan of Gavin
Newsom but he seems to be
being groomed to be that next spot so I
I don't I don't although remember Gavin
Pelosi and Biden Gavin Pelosi okay Gavin
and policy and Biden got together and
then Gavin made public statements with
Pelosi and he said I will not primary
him I will not run against Joe Biden I'm
not going to primary this President and
that was just what six weeks ago and
when is Gavin Newsom ever not lied
right I suppose gosh you know what I
need I need to rethink this yeah but I
think the least likely thing is that
they pull the rug to the point that
Kamala is President I think that's the
least likely thing I agree I think the
most likely thing is you said Pierce the
Veil I think that's a good way to put it
there's a veil with a sitting president
and you pierce the veil so somebody can
get behind there and say look no
politician has ever said I'm retiring
from the highest office in the land
you are yeah that was my next question
when Once the what's the last time that
an incumbent president did not actually
run not win I'm not saying that when did
they not run
all right when's the last time that
happened I believe it's Lyndon Johnson
at the height of the Vietnam War where
he said I will not seek and I will not
pursue my uh party's nomination for
president those LBJ after he took over
after JFK after he won against yeah
because he served two terms at that
point yeah JFK's he sure has served one
and a half correct he served the half
then he was re-elected in 64 and then 68
I believe it was LBJ that said I will
not seek and I will not pursue the
nomination it was a famous uh like
almost trembling uh Speech he gave on on
television he looked bad what do you
think would you as far as the question
you asked about odds Kamala running
female President Biden is that what
you're kind of predicting
you know they asked Draymond Green the
other day hey uh what do you think uh
with your chance of being a Golden State
Warrior long term he says no it's
inevitable my days are numbered is I'm
only going to be here for he says I
understand the business
of this game he says I understand
there's business with the NBA and my
time is coming and I'm probably gonna be
playing elsewhere this doesn't mean I
would like to be a career Golden State
Warrior but I don't think it's going to
be happening I think I'm going to be
going to a different place and then he
explained the pool story says one day I
will tell the real story that nobody
knows about the only thing you guys know
is me punching them but anyway so that's
a different story the writing's on the
wall right okay you know yesterday I
watched Brady play it's very hard to
watch the game it wasn't easy to watch
the game uh uh because of you know
everybody was who's a Brady guy was
rooting for a win he did not look good
don't get me wrong if you didn't watch
the game and you just go look at the
stat sheet you know 39 for 57 I don't
know the exact numbers it could be 37
459 352 yards two touchdowns one
interception it was not a good game it
was embarrassing it was not a good game
the extra point guy missing it four
times that wasn't the bigger story
because that's you know which wasn't
anyone ever done this by the way it's
1930 whenever the first season of the
NFL was 32 or 39 hasn't happened since
then but you watch and you're like okay
is this guy going to come back is he
going to come back or is he going to go
take his 360 plus million dollar
contract that he got and just go do TV
right because he can come back next year
you mean it's going to come back next
year I don't know if it's a good idea
for him to come back who's he going to
listen to his wife definitely didn't
work out customer's marriage his best
friends I don't know uh in the camp he's
got a lot of good people in the camp but
a guy like that is someone can someone
really tell him to stop yes now to
compare Brady and Joe Biden is like the
worst example to use on what you can do
there but there is timing to stepping
away and in the world of politics
whether you like this guy or don't like
this guy I don't agree with his policies
I don't think he's a leader but if
you're competing in the NBA you're
competing to win a what championship and
then if you're competing in the MBA
you're competing to win a championship
and in the finals you become a one
Finals MVP right what is considered the
finals MVP in politics being the
president he's become Finals MVP there's
only 46 finals MVP in the politics he's
one of them okay he's probably the worst
finals MVP maybe one of the worst Finals
MVP top 10 candidates yeah for worst
Finals MVP right but but the moral of
the story is guess what out of 113
billion people who have ever lived in
the world out of 330 million people
living in America today you are one of
330 million people that became you know
uh one no you're four or five of
whatever living right now that became
one of the finals MVP becoming a
president someone needs to sit down and
say look you need to step away I would
like it to not be through the
manipulative games for this person to
step away make sense because sometimes
you think you're bigger than the game
you no longer take counsel from anybody
in time the person we had lunch with
yesterday was given a very very very
interesting perspective one of the most
influential people in politics the last
50 years I'm sure you would agree with
that incredible he gave very good
Insight
um this this whole thing right now is on
one person and you know who it is Jill
Biden and JoJo it's all on her she needs
to kind of sit down and say babe it's on
her not joke it's on Jill to say Joe go
announce immediately you're not running
in 2024 and you're stepping away okay
because the last way you want to I
guarantee you if you went out there and
said that 90 of these issues would go
away I'm telling you right now I'm
convinced if he was to go out there and
say I am not running in 2024 you would
seek very quickly this disappearance go
away and that's a better way to leave
than no I'm gonna run they can't do
nothing now they're going to keep
finding [ __ ] on you if you've been in
politics for 48 years you have so much
dirt on you and they got a list of it
I'm willing to believe there's somebody
behind closed doors that they have one
job
you know what their job is they have a
file on 1800 people in politics ever and
every single dirt on them just waiting
to see when to use that dirt and they
have a number eight dirt they have a
number four dirt and they have a number
one dirt this is not Joe's top tender if
they want to use this number one it will
not be career ending it will be Legacy
ending where the last name Biden people
will the name Joe will go from being the
most common name that kids give their
names to Joe going on a name drought for
two decades okay if they pull up that
number one thing you're saying that
there might be more there's not there
might be there is more I'm convinced why
didn't they use that already or why
didn't they they don't need to use it
yet they don't need to use no why didn't
they use a lot of things on JFK you know
they why didn't they use a lot of things
on the part of what which Trump was the
most annoying person for the left
is because he didn't give a [ __ ] because
he would own the dirt yeah like you know
how he's talking about I asked him I
said what's the worst label you can give
somebody nowadays that's career ending
racist guess what Trump says about the
labels I don't give a [ __ ] yeah that's
that is power though
that is power every one of these guys
gives a [ __ ] he does not give a [ __ ] he
doesn't sit there and say you know it's
not it's not going to be yeah go ahead
yeah no problem oh yeah oh well how
about you how about this how about
crooked Hillary how about that the the
way he was a counter puncher he ruined
politics he ruined the these people who
had been game in politics four years he
ruined them the swamp this guy Jill is
in charge right now Jill needs to make a
decision to talk to her husband and Joe
needs to come out in the next two four
eight weeks and say hey after long
conversations with my wife and after a
visit with the doctor the doctors asked
me it is not a good idea for me to go
another four years there are plenty of
other great candidates in America like
Newsome like this he needs to give that
message written in the following way
looking that out a piece of paper where
he is edifying and indirectly you know
endorsing the next four five six eight
different candidates and then he's gonna
say I will do my part the greatest honor
of my life I will finish this term and
we will support the next Democratic
candidate to become the president that's
what I foresee happening anyways it may
not happen but that's what I'm going to
get your opinion on something Pat so
you're familiar with juxtaposition right
yeah so like
so here's my question if Trump runs
again obviously what she's already
declared
um don't you think he's rooting
for Biden to run against him meaning
that there's nothing speaking of
juxtaposition the last thing that Trump
wants is a young fresh Gavin Newsom just
like the last thing a Biden wants is a
young fresh Ron DeSantis like what would
be more alarming and shocking than
82 year old uh Joe Biden up on stage
debating young fresh energetic Ron
DeSantis polarity and Duality and
juxtaposition would be crazy same thing
with even a trump and
um our friend Newsome like don't the two
of them kind of want each other have my
thoughts but I'll let Tom address it I
don't think Joe Biden would want that I
don't think Donald Trump would care
because if you're a winner and you
believe in yourself you're like
whoever gets in the ring I'm coming and
I think that is what you see
in Donald Trump Donald Trump hasn't won
anything since 2016. yeah but but here's
the question for you here's the question
Brady lost the Super Bowl to Philly did
he stop being a winner he didn't win for
seven eight years he you know the
longest drop Brady had because under
West Welcome West played with him for
seven years they never won a Super Bowl
ever really never never West Walker
never won a Super Bowl you know what the
Belichick called West Welker one time in
the conversation with them you know who
Wally pip is Wally pip was at the time
the greatest New York Yankees first
baseman and then he missed one game one
time because of a headache you know who
replaced him 2 200 games Lou gehriguez
so anyways so so so meaning West West
Walker was replaced by Edelman and it
was game over it's a very epic scene
everybody has to see when Belichick
pulls up to uh uh what's his name and
says hey do you know who Wally pip is no
he says you may want to look up a Wally
pippas Wally pit missed the game one
time Lou Gehrig took it over and he says
it looks like we just had a Wally pit
moment right now he whispers it to Wes
Welker but going back to it I want you
to think about this think about the
three most painful events you had in
your life
you don't need to say publicly just
think about it okay
how quickly did you recover from it
that's the question okay think about the
most painful humiliating moment of your
life and how quickly you recovered from
it
now if you're emotionally there and
you're thinking about that moment
the day they're raiding Mar-A-Lago Trump
is golfing
I want you to actually think about this
so imagine you get a call hey Mr Mr
saucenick they're raiding your place
yeah okay who what do you mean I called
the lawyer call this call that okay all
right four
once again actually emotionally go there
the average person when that happens
cancel the game I gotta go
he's like nah let's finish the game he
loves golf it's not about he loves golf
this isn't about he loves golf you could
love basketball you could be playing a
pickup game you know he could be playing
badminton right saying his own face it
could be it could be anything it's the
fact that
the average person overreacts
and he just moves on and he plays his
game and there isn't any game that
you're gonna play worse and then golf
because it's small little stress levels
the ball is going to travel one way or
another this is why you know guys who
are dealing with the kind of personal
issues they were dealing with and
winning tournaments you sit there and
you're like how the hell can you do that
at the levels that you do
so the point to your question is I don't
care I don't think he cares who he faces
I think he want thinks he can beat
anybody I didn't tell you he's going to
I said that's his mindset he thinks he
can beat anybody he thinks he is the guy
to beat and uh to be to be even a little
bit more uh specific about it he thinks
somebody else has his job right now that
doesn't deserve to have his job in his
mind that's what he thinks he thinks
this is his job he has to finish his
term and he took that four years away
from him to make America great again
whether the populace believes that or
not that's what he thinks that's what
I'm convinced he thinks
um
when you meet people like that
it takes very few people to understand
who that person is one of the greatest
quotes of all time that I have in my one
of my vision boards if a lion could
speak
the world could not understand them
you can't understand the lion
the average person is impossible to
understand the line
it's not possible to understand why
would Jordan be the way he was why would
a guy who's constantly wanting to win
and wants that to be the way why is
Brady why is Brady still playing can you
imagine this year he goes through a
divorce right after his divorce he goes
on a 3-1 streak what would the average
person do that goes through a divorce uh
Tom Brady has taken uh time off for
personal reasons the average player
would do that didn't happen with Brady
and he finished the season love him or
hate him this is probably the most
dramatic year in his personal life not
career you know deflategate all this
other stuff personal life I think I
finished the season I don't care he had
a bad ending the guy finished the season
there are there are people like that and
trumps in that camp that he likes these
types of things he doesn't hide from it
and I know it's not what a lot of people
want to say because right now what's
most popular is you know trashing
trashing trashing by the way the other
part with this whole thing that's going
on right now with Biden and Trump
they're trying to eliminate two people
okay so if you eliminate two take these
two out
take time take Biden and Trump out of
the equation who becomes president
yeah probably let's play this game so
again take by eliminate Biden and Trump
who's President well the most likely to
in terms of um current playing field
would be Newsom and DeSantis however
if
people keep forgetting about Michelle
Obama okay so now let me get the other
one take Biden out leave Trump in who
becomes president
let me ask the question one more time
take Biden out Trump is able to run they
don't do anything to Trump but Biden is
saying he's not going to run who becomes
president oh I I think Trump would beat
Newsom but he would not beat Michelle
Obama okay so let's take Trump that's
the kind of handicap let's take Trump
out Obama Biden runs Trump is not
running who becomes president
wow like that yes I think there's just
such a yearning in this country for if
you're 75 and older thank you for your
service wow peace out okay I think
there's such a yearning whether you're
on the left you're on the right there's
such a a a major advocacy on the left
and on especially on the right to get to
biting the hell out of there and the
same rules apply to Trump and that's why
I think there's there's like Gavin
Newsom has done nothing in his career
he's ruining California why the hell is
he at the top of this list to run for
the Democratic nominee it's because he
looks the part and they're just grooming
someone to take the place of Biden
for all we know about DeSantis he's done
a way better job than Gavin Newsom but
there's such a yearning in in the
country to be like that's the new guy
and whether Trump wants to step out of
the way or not remains to be seen but
I'll always revisit that people want
these 75
octogenarians out of there well and
DeSantis has his flaws I'm saying if
Biden is pushed or he pushes and he's
the candidate and DeSantis
you know gets the nomination I think the
Sanders can beat
Biden but DeSantis himself is not a
perfect candidate decided the scientists
would mop the floor with Joe Biden mop
the floor and sadly but true I think
Gavin just Newsom would actually beat
Donald Trump
oh Gavin Newsom beats Donald Trump I
think so
yes
when you go to Miami this weekend go
with security okay I'll do my best you
just said that because again I'm not a
fighter I'm not a fan of Newsome in the
least I just know how these these have
you seen Democratic operations work have
you seen a couple months ago when
Michelle Obama had a hard time endorsing
Joe Biden a lot of people have had that
but did you see that or no well I didn't
say that you haven't seen it so if you
if you talk go to YouTube and just type
in Michelle Obama on Biden just type in
Michelle Obama on Biden it's a short
yeah she was kind of cornered by the
question and how she kind of the threat
was kind of oh no no just go to YouTube
just go on YouTube yeah and then just
type in Michelle Obama on Biden it's 16
seconds Michelle Obama on Biden he's
hard to defend it's like stumbles yeah
the first one right there watch that and
press the audio so everybody can hear it
one time do you hope that President
Biden will run again in 2024. you know I
I
I
will have to see
how many eyes was that by the way you
know what I think I heard a giggity you
know what's my biggest thing with that I
mean Michelle Obama your husband was a
two-term president you've been in
politics your entire life pretty much
you mean to tell me your publicist
didn't give you a list of possible
questions they're going to ask for you
to answer the way you did that's the
number one what do you think they're
going to ask
by the way I think I think you need to
have a candy well you know I've known
Joe for a long time he was a great vice
president I think he's doing a great job
I'd look forward to endorsing them you
have a canned response your canned
response should not be oh
great for this country I think he's done
this what he's done his best yeah I
think that was a canned response yikes
Pat can I just circling back to our
group 30 seconds circling back yeah or I
guess Dennis Prager there's something
about him that's just very unique he's a
very calm presence although I think he's
very good for you you think so I okay if
you if you knew his background he is
you're more him than you know thank you
meaning not in a way I'm not talking I'm
not sitting here saying you're as well
read and as wise and you were the guy at
14 years old that you were gonna fight
evil I didn't say that I just think
there's a lot you can pick up from this
guy this would be a person that if
you're gonna if you're gonna study
anybody's content this guy would be one
of the guys to add to your list to study
I agree well I've been studying Dennis
for years I I and I thank you for
putting me uh me and Dennis Prager
don't get too cocky man I meant it in a
different way yeah but my question to is
what is it about him that resonates with
you so much listen for me you have to
know a great conversation to me is what
porn is to a 16 year old kid to a two
boy that's what it is I just love great
conversation in my head right there to
me when whenever I'm having a very high
high level conversation I'm having a
great time there's nothing like there's
something very unique about a very good
conversation and you have that every
single time with Dennis Prager anyways
gang I'm on the road this week we're
traveling all over the place he'll be
doing stuff I got nothing going on I'll
be on the road again I think uh Rob are
we doing podcasts next week or no
is it two times next week or just one
snakes I believe next Tuesday we have
Brett Weinstein and then Thursday we
have a home team podcast with Mike Baker
oh really Brett weissing is going to be
on yes next Tuesday that's right so
that's the date fantastic yeah we've
been talking here now so I'm looking
forward to that anyways gank have a
great week a great weekend and we'll do
this again next Tuesday take care
everybody bye-bye